The joe rogan experience,
Joe Rogan podcast all day.
Every part of that same,
yeah,
it's the greatest scene in a fucking horror movie.
I'll usually just go out and they wake up or something or just changes.
But yeah,
it felt like Alan,
this kills you problems or breaking apart.
That seems like more like what it would feel like.
Why is he,
I'm sorry,
I called your meatloaf.
He had his friend Jack had come back from beyond the grave and it was all
covered in like rotten flesh news,
calling a meatloaf,
just having visions as he was turning into a werewolf,
like leading up to it.
Uh,
yeah,
yeah.
He was being visited by dead people that the Werewolf killed.
So it was his friend Jack First,
and then it was until the blood line is broken,
those people are stuck in like a purgatory state and only the Werewolf can see
them and they're all just rotting.
And so they become like these talking skeletons.
Wow.
Yeah.
And that's what we told you when we get this beautiful.
Let's do it right.
Three,
give me some great time.
I'm getting a full live life size version of the Werewolf from the American
Werewolf in London.
Bill
decorating studio.
Lynn,
come on Friday night.
That isn't,
that's one of the coolest fucking things I've ever seen in my life that come in
here and get afraid.
We can only hope so
fucking long gun thing.
My kids going to hate it though.
So you see the other guys I me from the movie?
No.
What else did they do?
A full size jack.
What do you call like the puppet theater theater.
I do a version of him.
You know,
they made a coal Paris.
You had one of the greatest horror movies of all time.
Great.
What's that?
Am I ready?
Rick Baker has one.
It is.
I'm still going to these to Rick Baker.
Angelman is,
wow,
dude,
this is gone.
I love the,
the saliva and the blood.
God,
it's amazing.
That's perfect.
Yeah.
Just enough to maybe
just making sure there's no Saunders.
It's not,
I guess got accurate.
That's so amazing.
Wow.
[inaudible]
okay.